yeah thanks thanks so much the
organizers for having me yeah so this is
part two of Jonathan and eyes asset
obsession with the finite convolutions
but from a different point of view and
this time with more theorems so I'm
gonna kind of go over some things that
probably are pretty basic but I'll try
to move through them quickly so the
point of view that I'm looking at this
from is one that we're all very familiar
with real rooted polynomials used to
encode information about common toriel
objects I'm interested in either in
terms of the roots or the coefficients
and the main power of this interface is
that operations on the combinatorial
objects I care about correspond to
linear operations on these polynomials
and so under this interface then I'm
really interested in questions about
linear operators and so there's some
classic ones which have been referenced
here which are the pulley oh sure three
questions which linear operators
preserve the set of all real rooted
polynomials and also which linear
operators preserve the set of real
reader polynomials of bounded degree
these are two separate questions and
they're classic questions and what I'm
going to look at today is an abstraction
of these questions so I'm going to call
a polynomial one mesh if it's real
rooted and the minimal distance between
any pair of roots is 1 so this gives
some condition on the spacing of the
roots and so we have these two discrete
pulley assure questions which linear
operators preserve the set of one mesh
rooted polynomials and which linear
operators preserve the set of one mesh
rooted polynomials of degree at most n
so I'm going to talk a little bit of the
background of this theory and talk about
our contributions
so let's start with some really basic
stuff in the world of real rooted
polynomials and see how that abstracts
and relates to things in the the finite
difference realm so we're very familiar
with the fact that derivative preserves
real rudeness and an instructive way to
see this is to study the graph of P
prime over P it's a graph you've
probably seen before
and by studying the graph of P prime
over P we noticed that the the zeroes of
this graph are exactly the zeroes of the
numerator which encapsulate the fact
that P prime is real rooted and if I
move the x-axis which corresponds to
shifting this graph this function up or
down then I will get exactly n real
roots no matter which way I move it
which corresponds the fact that P prime
minus alpha P is real rooted for any
alpha so we get this nice result a very
standard result and we can compose these
then so if the operator I minus alpha I
D is real rooted for any alpha I then if
I compose these operators I get real
rudeness and so I like to think of this
guy right here as a a polynomial in D
and it's a polynomial in D where if I
wrote it of P of D then P would have
real roots and so we could ask more
generally which polynomials in D which
I'll call differential operators
preserve real rootedness of unbounded
degree and it's a theorem an older
theorem that the differential operators
which preserve all real rooted
polynomials are exactly the ones which
come from a real rooted P so how does
this relate to the mesh case so first
let's do some definitions so like I said
earlier I'm going to call the minimal
distance between two roots of a
polynomial its mesh and we say a
polynomial is b mesh if it's real rooted
with mesh at least B so any real rooted
polynomial is going to be 0 mesh because
the minimal distance will be at least as
0 and there's a nice characterization of
B mesh in terms of interlacing that I'll
be using a lot throughout this talk so
here I've picked some arbitrary
polynomial P with these brown dots and
I've shifted it to the right by B with
these blue dots and what does it mean
for to be be mesh and equivalent thing
to say is that this shift interlaces my
original polynomial nice there's also an
equivalent definition which is like kind
of the multiplicative definition so if I
have a positive rooted polynomial I
could look at the minimal ratio between
roots where you know maybe I'll pick the
convention where I'm always looking at
the ratio of the larger route to the
smaller route and I say it's Q mesh if
that ratio is bounded below by Q you
could also do it the inverse way okay so
how what can we leverage from this
interlacing fact so P of X and P of X
minus B interlace and so I can look at
my picture again and I get a very
similar picture by interlacing so here
the blue dots are the roots of P the
numerator and the brown dots are the
roots of the shift of P and now what
happens when I shift the graph well the
key observation is that these black
intervals here are exactly b units long
because all it is is a shift of B and so
if I shift my x axis up what happens I
get roots which lie between these
unmarked this unmarked interval right
here and I think of the distance between
these roots within each of these
intervals between these green roots
I have a black interval and there's
black interval like I said is exactly
distance B so this proves that these
green roots have to be at least be apart
but notice if I would have gone the
other way I would not have gotten such a
result because I could have had my roots
coming in much quicker on one of the
intervals here than on the other so the
spacing could become less than B and so
we see when we look at what it means to
shift up I get this polynomial identity
minus alpha shift and now I've seen
identity minus alpha shift it will also
be B mesh if alpha is positive
so we need to play the same game so I'm
gonna call s the shift operator here
shifting to the right and I can compose
them so now I get a polynomial and shift
operators and I see that this polynomial
is going to preserve be mesh when the
roots of this polynomial are positive or
non-negative ask the same question which
shift operators preserve be mesh and
this is a theorem of brundin Krusty
Calvin Shapiro from 2016 then a shift
operator preserves the set of all sorry
this should say a shift operator
preserves a set of all B mesh
polynomials if and only if this
polynomial is real rooted with
non-negative roots so we get it so that
we've shown one direction here the kind
of simple direction the converse
direction that they prove
okay so what have we done we've remember
the pulley asure question the first one
is which linear operators preserve B
mesh polynomials of all degree and we've
answered the question for a very
specific type of very specific family of
operators namely operators that are
polynomial in the shift operator there's
another type of classic family of linear
operators that were studied and that's
diagonal operators and diagonal
operators are just those for which x
decay is an eigenvector and there's a
classical theorem of polisher which says
that a diagonal linear operator
preserves the space of all real rooted
polynomials if and only if T of e to the
X is a limit of either positive or
negative rooted polynomials and what is
T of e to the X mean well think of e to
the X as a power series and since T is
diagonal we're just applying to each
monomial in that power series and so
there's an equivalent result here that
was proved by lamp rect in 2016 so we
have to unpack this so this one is no
longer about be mesh like the this shift
operator one was this one's about log
mesh so the the ratios of the roots and
it says that a diagonal operator
preserves the set of Q log mesh
polynomials if and only if T of the Q
exponential function is the limit of
either positive or negative rooted Q log
mesh polynomials and here the Q
exponential function is this guy and
notice that if I let Q limit to 1 what
happens
well maybe not obvious but if I like Q
limit to 1 under appropriate
normalization here I'll get the
exponential function I need to normalize
things and down here the set of one log
mesh polynomials is just all positive
real on this so I recover
so that answers the the first question
of polio sure in the discrete setting
for two families of operators shift
operators and diagonal operators you can
ask what about the general case so
there's the butchaiah brand end result
of 2008 which says which classifies
linear transformations which preserve
rail rudeness
you can ask can we get something like
this in this case and I am I'm curious I
don't not know the answer to that so you
needed a multivariate notion of B mesh
or Q log mesh or the combination of the
two
and I have some ideas about this but
currently this is still open
okay so that talks about the unbounded
linear operator case what about the
bounded linear operator case so why
would we study the bounded linear
operator case well the set of Paul are
the set of linear transformations which
preserves bounded degree is gonna be
larger than the set of transformations
which preserves all unbounded degree and
often in applications when I have
encoded my comma trail object I am
looking I'm interested in studying
polynomials about a degree so this gives
us more flexibility and so this is just
a very small example of a differential
operator I preserves all real rooted
quadratic polynomials but does not
preserve all real rooted polynomials and
in fact P is not real rooted
okay so enter the additive convolutions
for the third time I won't belabor this
because we've seen this before
although maybe you we yeah I think we've
seen both these definitions so you can
write the idea of convolution as a
differential operator and Jonathan was
great to point out a lot of properties
of this we can think of this as
representing any arbitrary a
differential operator and it has nice
properties like commutation with shift
with scalars with derivatives it's
commutative associative so on so on we
have the multiplicative convolution
defined kind of on a basis so it's come
more of a diagonal action and it also
has many of those same properties and I
just want to quickly point out the two
other definitions that we've seen
there's a random matrix interpretation
which shows up a lot in applications and
there's the root definition which
Jonathan also mentioned which I will use
later
okay so a theorem that was mentioned
earlier is that a real differential
operator preserves polynomials have
bound a degree at most n if and only if
it can be written as additive
convolution by a fixed polynomial so
let's go back to that example I had here
my example was d squared plus du 2d plus
2i this comes from a polynomial which is
not real rooted but can be written as
convolution by a real rooted polynomial
so this tells us right here since X plus
1 squared is real rooted added leaked
involving with it will preserve the
space of quadratic real rooted
polynomials but because it doesn't come
from a real rooted polynomial itself as
a differential operator it's not going
to preserve all real rated polynomials
so this is in my opinion the crux of why
the additive convolution is so powerful
and we get a similar result for the
multiplicative convolution this time
with positive rooted polynomials and yet
again Portilla Brent brundin in 2008
proved a result which covers all linear
operators which preserve bounded degree
River tunas
okay so our path clear or a path forward
is to figure out if we can mimic these
results so I'm going to kind of show you
really basic combination of properties
that I'm gonna leverage multiple times
in this talk and that is that the
additive convolution preserves
interlacing you can see this for the
classical out of the convolution from
the fact that it's bilinear and it's
real routed preserving and also that it
commutes with shift and combining these
I'm gonna get mesh preservation so let's
see how I can do that so I start off
with a polynomial that's B mesh and yet
again that means that P is interlaced by
its B shift
I now convolve by any real rooted
polynomial and I know convolving by a
fixed reverted polynomial is going to
preserve interlacing so I know P
convolve are is gonna be interlaced by
the P shift convolve are and now I can
commute my shift out of the operation
from shift commuting at the additive
convolution and ICP convolve are is
actually interlaced by peak involved are
shifted and therefore peak involve are
is itself a be mesh polynomial so we see
the classical additive convolution
preserves mesh and this backs up the
intuition that Jonathan was talking
about we have this intuition that the
additive convolution is constantly
spreading roots and this is one way to
quantify that it says if you take any
two polynomials and you Adeleke involve
them the minimal distance between them
is the max of the minimal distances of
your inputs so you can never shrink
roots in there are a lot of other ways
to quantify this there's the entropy
conjecture that people are really
interested in there's some modularity
stuff but this is just one way to
quantify that
and you get the same thing for the
classical log mesh preservation so
nothing I've written here is
particularly deep but notice what what
this says so what does it say if I fix a
be mesh polynomial P then that linear
transformation will send any real rooted
polynomial R to a be mesh polynomial
which is the additive convolution of
them so I end up with linear
transformations which send real rooted
polynomials to be mesh polynomials and
that's not what I'm particularly
interested in I'm really interested in
the more general question of sending B
mesh polynomials to be mesh monomials
not real rooted plant Emile's to be mesh
polynomials so what do we do we look at
finite differences so some of these are
probably familiar and maybe some of
these are not so this is just the
additive finite difference if I limit B
to 0 I get the classical derivative this
is the what's usually called the Q
derivative and this I'll call the polar
Q derivative and if I so these are well
studied objects and FISC in fact in his
giant book of polynomials has a whole
chapter about affine transformations and
how they affect polynomials and he
studied a lot of properties about these
kind of things one of the nice things he
proves which is is pretty elementary to
show is that the finite difference
preserves be mesh and both of these Q
derivatives preserve Q log mesh and so
we can think of these as generalizations
of what's happening the classical case
when I limit B to 0 I'll recover the
classical derivative here and when I
live it limit Q to 1 I'll recover both
the classical derivative here and the
polar derivative the respect to 0 here
so maybe dy
and so now I have this kind of picture
in my head I have the classical case the
classical realm where I have tools like
real rudeness and the classical
derivative and I have their
corresponding tools in the finite
difference case like B mesh and the
finite difference I do I defined a kind
of obvious abstraction in the eyelet of
case at least so for the out of case I
just replied replace my derivatives with
my finite differences in Oh polluted
case I have to replace things with
something maybe not as natural but these
are q binomial coefficients scale than a
prop in a appropriate way and so a
theorem of lamp rect from 2016 is that
if P and R both have Q log mesh then the
Q multiplicative convolution has Q log
mesh and it should be noted that this is
like tight in a way so if I for example
take a Q log mesh polynomial P and a
real positive root of polynomial R I
won't even get a positive rooted pulling
it out I'll just get something maybe
with complex roots so the Q log mesh
really is a boundary condition for this
convolution and so Jonathan nice theorem
is the same thing but for the additive
convolution and this was originally
conjectured by brundin and Shapiro and
krasnikov in 2016 this additive version
in the same paper they proved the
unbounded version
okay so this is this is what we're going
to set out to prove now
any questions about the setup
yes
oh yeah it should be mentioned that this
all kind of lamp racks proof and lamp
Rex results are all inspired by papers
from the 70s a suffrage where he looked
at similar results for circle rooted
polynomials but he he ran across this
from a completely different field in a
completely different way studying
star-like domains and the such so it's a
pretty interesting crossover
okay so Jonathan and I approve this
theorem in two separate ways we kind of
proved them simultaneously in these two
ways one way we do it is by taking lamb
pact preps proof distilling it down to
what it needs and making the appropriate
modifications for the out of case so his
proof doesn't just copy over to the out
of case which is I presume why he didn't
do it but once you make the appropriate
modifications and you realize what you
need to substitute in you can get it
simultaneously we didn't really think
that this would work so we asked him
more general question which is how can
you take results about multiplicative
convolutions and transfer them over to
additive convolutions just in a very
generic way and we developed a framework
to do this so I'm gonna talk about both
of those methods here so like I said the
main thing we like to do interlacing
preservation + shift commuting it's
going to give us mesh results this was
lamp racks main idea if you he proved
this for the cue multiplicative
convolution if you take a cue log mesh
polynomial P & R and s here are just
positive rooted not Q log mesh then
oh I lied earlier okay if you have PQ
log message it does preserver over than
this then P being Q log mesh so if R and
s interlace then P being Q log mesh and
implies that this convolution by P will
also preserve interlacing and just like
we saw earlier from the fact that we get
commuting through the additive
convolution once we get interlacing
preservation which is the main theorem
of land pract we're in fact going to get
mesh results so we're gonna get this
result down here that the log mesh of
the output of to Q log mesh polynomials
is going to be Q log mesh so the
cumulative convolution preserves log
mesh and this is our theorem we proved
when we're mimicking lamp racks result
we do the same thing for the additive so
the main thing to take from this slide I
know a lot of words is that
interrelation interlacing preservation
is key
you might try to set out to just prove
the fact that mesh is preserved under
these out of convolutions and that's
pretty tricky and it's not clear how to
proceed really what you should do is
prove the stronger result that you get
interlacing preservation and that will
with shift commuting imply mesh results
and I think there's some really
interesting things that he does that we
hadn't run across before that I want to
just kind of point out here so in
general when you talk when you when you
people talk about linear operators that
preserve interlacing often they'll say
something like a linear operator which
preserves all real real polynomials
preserves interlacing but we don't have
that here and so we need another
criterion and our criterion or land
precariat area I should say is based on
the this really nice observation so if
you fix the polynomial F and you look at
all polynomials which are interlaced by
F it's a cone in the space of
polynomials and that cone is finally
generated and it has really nice
generators it's generated by F negative
F and all polynomials you obtain by
taking F and removing one of the roots
so it's pretty easy to convince yourself
that all of these things are interlaced
by F and then it's maybe less easy to
convince yourself but not so difficult
to do that all things that are
interlaced by F are in this cone and you
can do this using a partial fraction
decomposition
and so now what we want to do if we want
to show a linear operator T preserves
interlacing with respect to a specific
polynomial F we just need to check it on
these generators and this is my
impression he takes the generators he
induct son degree and he uses the nice
properties commuting relations and Q log
preservation of his two nice derivatives
but his his proof really needs a polar
derivative and it turns out in the out
of case you don't get a polar derivative
so this is the natural polar derivative
don't worry too much about the symbols
but just worried about this punchline it
doesn't preserve be mesh so you try to
construct what would be the natural
polar derivative the the DUI alternative
in the finite difference case it doesn't
exist and so it's proof falls apart and
so instead we kind of come up with an
approximation to it so we have this nice
technical lemma which says if you fix a
specific polynomial F then you can take
a pole that's really close to zero and
four poles close enough to zero your
polar derivative will preserve be mesh
and it'll have the interlacing
properties you want so you don't get a
universal polar derivative that works
for all F but for fixed F you can find
an appropriate polar derivative and this
is fine because at the end of the day
the kind of results we want to prove are
that be mesh convolution with respect to
a fixed polynomial preserves interlacing
so we've already fixed the polynomial in
our argument and so we can get away with
this kind of a substitution
okay so that's land pressure proof I
think it's nice
because it contains a lot of nice ideas
but for the most part their land parks
ideas so what about our contribution so
how do I transfer results from a
multiplicative setting to the additive
setting so in general there's all kinds
of results that people care about for
these convolutions and if you look at
any of the papers that prove them they
prove them separately for multiplicative
an additive every time you know and
sometimes it can be very tedious to do
that so even like off this list is the
MSS results which they also prove
separately from multiplicative and
additive and so we came up with the
question can we I mean it seems like
every time you come up with a result for
one you get a result for the other there
must be some connection between the two
okay so I'm gonna go through a bit of a
calculation here hopefully the colors
will make it doable so let's start off
with the multiplicative convolution I
write the multiplicative convolution
down in the root form yet again I'm
summing over all but I can think of as
matchings between the roots of p and r
where this polynomial right here the
it's a polynomial degree n where the
roots are just pairwise products of
polynomials are of roots of P times
roots of our I'm summing over all
possible pairings I want to somehow make
this additive so what I do is I
introduce a new variable I introduce a
new variable Q and I normalize don't
worry too much of the normalization so
when I do this change of variables I
input my new variable Q and all the dust
settles what happens is I end up down
here with something X some constant and
now the linear part with respect to what
am I is Q looks like the additive
convolution and then some air so if I
now post compose to make this part look
nicer
but do I end up with I end up with the
additive convolution plus some error
term that goes to zero as q goes to one
this shows this theorem that by pre
composing and post composing by the
appropriate functions in Q and X and
limiting Q to one I can take the
multiplicative convolution to the
additive convolution you notice this all
makes sense these are still polynomials
in X so the multiplicative convolution
is well-defined I can post compose here
everything is good and in fact this
converges uniformly on compact sets but
this is a kind of a mess so what's the
intuition here well there's actually is
a really nice intuition I think so we
would like to think of this as
exponentiating and taking log of the
roots and this is kind of what is
happening so if I wanted to exponentiate
my roots what I could think of doing is
pre composing by log of base Q of X now
this doesn't really make sense because I
take a polynomial and I end up with a
polynomial and log but at least the real
zeros will go like this this is the
transformation on the real zeros and I
could do the same thing over here with a
logarithm of roots and so you know I
have this intuition that I have
this formula for the multiplicative
convolution if I could exponentiate my
roots
then I'd end up here of course now I get
this and now after all the dust settles
I'm going to try to take a log of my
roots so first i exponentiate then I
take multiplicative convolution then I
take log this is kind of what I'd hope
to happen
this is vague because it's intentionally
I mean it's not actually what's
happening but it's the intuition for
what's happening because
if you take log base Q of X and you
write it as a Lorentz series in Q and X
about 1 the first term that appears is 1
minus X over 1 minus Q so this is the
crudest approximation you could take to
it
now you take Q to the X and you do the
same thing this is your linear
approximation so in a way we're taking
linear approximations of these of course
this is not going to give us a true
result for any Q but by limiting it
washes away what's happening this is the
intuition on how to connect the
multiplicative the additive and I wanted
to show you a really silly toy example
to show how this could take results from
the multiplicative realm and put them
into the additive realm so I'm gonna
take the result that the multiplicative
convolution preserves positive rudeness
and I'm going to make that into a result
that the additive convolution preserves
real rudeness here I put Q to the X in
here this is actually what we proved we
didn't use the the linear approximation
of it you can use either but in our
paper we constantly use Q to the X but
we do need to use this approximation for
log because it does not make sense to
plug in anything here because the
multiplet convolution is only defined on
polynomials so we really do need the the
log approximation in my pre composition
so I take two polynomials which are real
rooted and I want to show that this is
real rooted so what happens when I apply
this this this pre composition to them
well the roots go to 1 minus 1 minus QA
I so as Q goes to 1 these roots are
getting really close to 1 so for Q close
enough to 1 my roots are positive which
means these two polynomials have
positive roots and this preserves
positive rudeness so when I have by
hypothesis so when I do the
multiplicative convolution I get
positive rudeness
so now what happens when I compose Q to
the X well you know I have to be a
little bit worried because I have
infinitely many roots but basically the
the band on which I have roots is
growing large as q approaches one and
this converges uniformly in compact sets
which we show and so because this has
positive roots the real roots of the
thing that this converges to will also
have are sorry the roots of the thing
that this converges to will also have
real roots and so we can easily get that
P out of 12 R is real rooted just from
this back I mean this is a very silly
example you can prove these things in a
million ways neither of these results
are difficult but for an example of a
difficult result or somewhat difficult
result would be the one that we want to
show so we have the Q multiplicative
convolution preserves Q log match we
want to show that that implies the be
added convolution preserves be mesh and
this is where things get really tricky
so what happens if you start with if you
will replace the multiplicative
convolution with just additive and then
do this funky operation what does it
become
like multiplication becomes certain
addition what happens to addition you
know
I mean I guess you would roughly assume
like you would start with addition here
exponentiate log I mean you can roughly
get some intuition based on that but I
don't have a better answer than that
yeah yeah definitely something to
you get a negative roots and something
like yeah you'd probably need to start
off with positive roots or even in that
case you might need to start off with
roots greater than one but I mean you
can always kind of play these games
okay so how do we get to the Q and B
coalition's well it's messy so the Q and
B convolutions I wrote down their
definition right I wrote down their
definition in terms of Q Drive or in
terms of Q binomial coefficients and B
find differences those are the only
definitions there are there's no root
definition there's no random matrix
model and so I can't do the root trick I
did though you know one page proof of
the classical one and so we get to a lot
of combinatorics we define this map on
raising B factorials which maps raising
P factorials to coupon camera symbols
and we just extend linearly so this is a
basis of polynomials of degree n so we
extend this map linearly and our theorem
is that this is going to be the
substitute for exponentiating our roots
but we can't do anything clever here
anymore because notice this is no longer
pre composition before he was pre
composition everything was so
well-behaved now we just have some
linear map which is defined on some
horrible basis and but we do prove this
this is this is true a uniformly on
compact sets and the way we prove it is
based on this Q l'orange interpolation
formula this is a pretty cool formula
it's just like LaGrant interpolation
except it does everything in terms of Q
binomial coefficients and so using this
and some careful you know comma torques
we get this this theorem and I don't
really write it but just in the way that
the toy examples happen you can use this
theorem to then take the result that Q
the Q multiplicative multiplicative
convolution preserves Q log mesh and you
can get the fact the be additive
convolution preserves be mesh so this
serves as an interface between these two
generalized realms I should say on this
slide this is very mysterious to
Jonathan and I I would love an
explanation for what's happening there's
I have some rough intuitions about how
like maybe this corresponds somehow to
the Q exponential one of the Q
exponential functions and taking
truncations of it or something but I
really don't know
I think there should be some better
analytic explanation than that's
happening here rather than just look at
this queue LaGrant interpolation formula
and it happens to work so there's still
questions to be had here
okay I would be remiss if I didn't say
something about MSS so as Jonathan
talked about in the last talk some
modularity we love it it's a really
great thing does some modularity exist
in the be additive realm and that's a
conjecture so you know you you you take
you alpha instead of one minus alpha D
now you do one minus alpha finite
difference there's a some technical note
here where you have to do the the shift
the other way to bound things from above
you get immediately a triangle in
equality it's not hard to prove but then
the question is can you get something
stronger so this would give you the you
know if you have some polynomials are
interested in studying that are defined
by finite difference equations and you'd
be able to get really fine control over
the roots using this method and this is
another example of where I think you
know there's something that we're
missing here for the sub modularity
proof because if you try to extend the
methods that we're currently known for
some modularity they just they fall
apart and that's just something in
general that I think it's really
interesting about this B out of and Q
multiplicative realm from a theory point
of view is that often when you have a
result in the real polynomial case the
real root of polynomial case you can
generalize it to the be additive case
and the be out case is strictly more
general when you limit B to 0 you
recover your original result but the
tools at your disposal the be additive
case are much more limited which means
if you have some result that you think
abstractly to be out of case you should
be able to prove it in that realm using
your limited tools and all those tools
limit to tools in the real root case so
this to me implies that there should be
some way to prove sub modularity using
only things like interlacing and polar
derivatives which is very far from the
current proof because you know that's
kind of all we have here at the moment
or maybe we need some really new
machinery and the the be mesh world but
I think it actually is helpful to limit
the tools you have when working with
real really polynomials because there's
so much out there and it's pretty
interesting to test if you think that
there's a generalization the B mesh
world to limit those tools appropriately
so yeah limiting alpha to zero just like
before in the classical case gets you
the triangle equality and limiting B to
zero will limit these finite differences
to derivatives so you'll recover
the MSS result for the classical
convolutions okay and just a few words
about future directions yeah I think the
most interesting question to me is is
there a classification of all linear
operators which preserve one-match
polynomials just discrete Polly oh sure
theory in a nutshell this is a hard
question I think we've kind of answered
the most obvious questions at this point
and if you look at it it seems like the
the be additive and the Q multiplicative
realms are splitting real polynomial
theory in half right we take the the
results about difference operators those
become results about shift operators and
the be additive case you take results
about diagonal operator so it's become
results about the multiplicative the Q
multiplicative case they get log mesh
results so it's really interesting to me
to try to unify this theory I don't have
a way to do it at the moment and I think
key to this of course just a la patria
and Brandon is is there an analog of
real stability and so it's I mean it's
really unclear when with the analog of
meshes from multivariate I don't think
it's a condition about spacing of the
roots per se or I mean it could be but
it's very unclear what it should be if
that's the case because you know these
things kind of become more ambiguous
when you have infinitely many roots and
yeah is there under if you came up with
an appropriate multivariate polynomial
form work could this explain its
connection in a much more intuitive way
and then finally is there a random
matrix model which interprets this so
this this Q stuff in particular is
really interesting and you know Q stuff
shows up a lot in quantumly algebras and
you often have some non commutative ring
which under in this non community bring
all these q identities just become true
and I'm pretty interested but I don't
know enough about this to pass judgment
on this so if anyone does it would be
really interested to see if we could
somehow get a random matrix model or
even just symbolically get something of
that that form which yields these
modified convolutions that's it
[Applause]
any questions
you expect us when the matrix model can
have some kind of discrete label yeah hi
I messed around with it for a while but
I really need to sit down with somebody
who has a lot of experience with I think
like somehow yeah underlying it it's
going to be some of this this well
studied quantum algebra stuff
Prius to see
[Applause]